[Musik]
windsbach dreißigste juli
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
setzt im rahmen eines festaktes den
spatenstich für die neuerrichtung eines
unterkunfts gebäudes in der von der
groeben kaserne in feldbach
der spatenstich erfolgte im rahmen einer
feierlichen angelobung von 60
soldatinnen und soldaten des aufklärungs
und artilleriebataillons 7 und mit allen
[Musik]
und dem österreichischen volk zu dienen
grundwehrdiener aus den bundesländern
steiermark kärnten niederösterreich und
salzburg werden in zukunft als
rettungssanitäter und im bereich der
versorgung tätig sein
um die volle einsatzbereitschaft des
bundesheeres zu erhalten
[Musik]
das neue unterkunftsgebäude wird als
holz riegel konstruktion errichtet und
gilt als besonders umweltschonend die
kosten des projekts betragen 7 millionen
euro